vous avez bien mangé hier trop mangé et
trop bu et maintenant vous avez la tête
lourde et la langue chargé et vous vous
demandez qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et
bien il y a d'abord des petits remèdes
qui ne valent rien le jus de chaud cûte
le crissant écrasé passant dessus est-ce
que le médicament classique qui consiste
à associer du bicarbonate de soude et de
l'aspirine est efficace et bien oui le
bicarbonate de soude ne fait pas digéré
parce que heureusement on a déjà digéré
mais il augmente les sécrétions acides
de l'estomac et lutte contre cette
impression de bouche pâteuse quant à
l'aspirine elle hate le mal de tête
faut-il jeûner au lendemain d'une fête
et bien les diététiciens disent non la
fête ça fatigue notre organisme a besoin
des apports reconstituants que sont ceux
de la viande et des vitamines il faut
manger légèrement par exemple une
tranche de jambon rose BIF froid salade
surtout il faut boire de l'eau beaucoup
d'eau l'eau est le premier et le
meilleur des médicaments contre ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement la gueule de bois